so to reiterate just once more using the
key dot prototype here instead of the
key dot methods is purely cosmetic don't
get confused thinking about the possible
effects that this might have on the
in-memory model at runtime since there
really aren't any here's some examples
of associations you might be making in
your mind that would mislead you first
of all the car function does not
delegate its failed lookups to the
object stored at car dot prototype there
is no such thing as car dot move for
example we never imagined that car would
delegate its failed lookups to car dot
methods and so we shouldn't expect the
car would delegate its failed lookups to
car dot prototype another point is that
result objects from the car function
only delegate to car dot prototype
because of our own call to this object
dot create function it's not because
we're using the key dot prototype to
store this object that we have a
relationship between instances and the
car dot prototype object so you should
really see this dot prototype object as
a freely provided object for storing
things with no additional special
characteristics mentally you can
substitute the word dot methods if it
helps you reason about it to underscore
my point observe that this example
function has the exact same relationship
with the car dot prototype object that
the car function does both functions
return objects that are set up to
delegate to the object stored at car dot
prototype
the fact that the prototype object is
stored as a property of only one of
those two functions is completely
immaterial both functions behave exactly
the same as they would if that prototype
object had been merely stored in some
global variable